bienvenue à la facture les HLM
habitation à loyer modique sont des
logements sociaux ou les loyers nacèdent
pas 25% des revenus des locataires la
majorité des HLM sont gérés par le
gouvernement voici l'histoire de trois
locataires qui ont dénoncé le mauvais
état de leur HLM et qui ont eu bien du
mal à se faire entendre
[Musique]
le 28 logements bâti lionne cinquantaine
d'années dès son arrivée en 2021 Nancy
Robbie show découvre des signes de
moisissures au sous-sol c'est très
évident les grosses pattes noires les
flaques d'eau et le ciment les
pointillés qui a de partout là
[Musique]
ressent rapidement un malaise au
sous-sol tout de suite les
étourdissements l'irritation la brûlait
toute la gorge héritée en feu cherchait
mon souffle pendant ce temps une autre
locataire de l'immeuble constate que des
articles de Noël entreposés ou sous-sol
ce sont des gradés certaines décorations
qui étaient surtout en tissu
il était tout vert des bougies vertes
aussi alors qui était rouge j'étais
obligé d'en acheter beaucoup en
avez-vous vu de la moisissure la seule
moisissure que j'ai vu c'était au
sous-sol à chaque fois que je reviens
ici je tombe malade infection pulmonaire
Carole Lavoie aux prises avec des
problèmes pulmonaires remarque que son
état s'améliore lorsqu'elle quitte
l'immeuble à l'hôpital les symptômes et
disparaissent quasiment toutes
un cancer constate le même phénomène
j'ai commencé à avoir de la misère à
respirer comme si j'avais des allergies
mais quand je m'en vais chez ma sœur ou
mes autres enfants j'ai posté problème
là les locataires se plaignent des
problèmes de moisissure à l'Office
régional d'habitation d'Argenteuil
l'organisme public qui gère 27 immeubles
dont le leur en 2021 Nancy Robbie show
va même jusqu'à payer plus de 500
dollars pour des analyses qui révèlent
la présence de moisissures au sous-sol
elle transmet les résultats à l'office
d'habitation cette directrice générale
Marie-Christine Godin accepte de
répondre à nos questions en fait
effectivement une liste de choses
qu'elle veut qu'on corrige en son
logement et nous fait part de
moisissures au niveau de son espace de
rangement au sous-sol son rangement a
été vérifié il y a rien qui a été
constaté donc vous voyez pas de problème
on doit pas de problème dans la foulée
des plaintes le fils effectue plusieurs
visites dans l'immeuble entre décembre
2021 et octobre 2022 l'organisme
commande même des tests d'air qu'il
refuse toutefois de nous transmettre et
procède à des inspections visuelles du
sous-sol notamment en compagnie
d'experts de la santé publique de
Laurentides
en ce moment selon les informations
qu'on a eu du département de la santé
publique on n'a pas de problème de
moisissures ok donc pas du tout de
problème de moisissure dans l'immeuble
c'est votre lecture de chez ma lecture
en réalité il y a bel et bien un
problème
trois semaines plus tôt nous avions cru
bon de visiter l'immeuble et tout
particulièrement le sous-sol le plafond
il y a de la moissure de l'autre côté
c'est noir de l'autre côté dans l'autre
la section quand madame Robichou se
plaint de ces moisissures dans son
espace de rangement ce que vous prenez
le temps de vérifier les autres espaces
de rangement c'est une vérification de
tous les espaces de rangement je peux
pas entrer dans un espace qui ne
m'appartient pas ça prend la demande du
locataire et la permission du locataire
mais on peut regarder oui ça c'est
la commune effectivement est-ce que vous
regardez à ce moment-là ce que vous
pouvez voir ça a été fait il y avait
rien de particulier il y avait rien de
particulier un simple coup d'œil plafond
nous indique le contraire nous
découvrons rapidement une structure de
bois endommagée dans l'air commune là où
c'était pourtant rendu des employés de
l'office et de la santé publique un mois
plus tôt intrigué nous poussons nos
recherches muni simplement d'un petit
escabeau et de nos cellulaires
de l'autre côté de la porte c'est encore
pire c'est noir au plafond la zone
touchée fait environ un mètre carré pour
en avoir le cœur net nous faisons appel
à une expert
on a plusieurs moisissures visibles sur
plusieurs types de matériaux on a du
Jeep affecté on a du bois aggloméré à
notre demande
l'aide de la
adésie
le rapport d'analyses aussi et sans
équivoque
marque Hamilton et président de
l'association des microbiologistes du
Québec nous lui avons soumis les
résultats on voit que dans les deux
échantillons prélevés qui me présente
élevée de moisissures qui sont
potentiellement pathogènes c'est des
contaminations qui sont normalement
élevées une contamination élevée avec
présence majoritaire d'Aspergillus
Pénicillium et de stackubotrices
c'est la moisissure qu'on ne veut pas
retrouver dans aucun bâtiment parce
qu'elle était reconnue comme vraiment
pathogène pour l'être humain elle a la
capacité de créer des mycotoxines donc
une personne qui respireait des sports
de moisissures de staki botris pendant
une certaine période pour être fortement
économique
depuis 25 ans le docteur Louis Jacques
s'intéresse à la santé des personnes
exposées au moisissures
ont tous on crache
on devient fatigué dans l'immeuble au
cœur de ce reportage les occupants de
trois des sept logements habités se
disent affectés par les moisissures le
docteur Louis Jacques n'est pas étonné
que des locataires à la santé fragile
puissent être incommodés des gens qui
ont déjà des problèmes respiratoires
peuvent voir leur maladie
aggravée ou déclenché ou effectivement
par la présence des moisissures et la
personne qui est immunisé en raison de
son traitement de shimothérapie mais
plus vulnérables à des infections qui
pourraient aussi la rendre dans une
experts sont formels il y a eu présence
de répéter pour qu’une telle
contamination surviennent et bien qu'il
soit impossible de mettre une date
précise sur ses moisissures elles ne
sont pas apparues la veille de notre
tournage ça doit pas dire parce qu'on
voit que les moisissures sont formés on
voit que c'est une contamination qui
atteint une certaine maturité un
contreplaqué ça se détériore pas
quelques mois comme ça nous montrant les
résultats d'analyse et nos images à la
responsable de l'Office régional
d'habitation d'Argenteuil je vois vos
images comment ça se fait que ça a pas
été trouvé par votre équipe écouter
c'est sûr que les employés sont de bonne
foi ils sont pas des experts en la
matière en moisissure donc ils ont fait
un visuel mais nous on n'est pas des
experts en moisissure puis on le trouve
en 15 minutes la tâche on veut
comprendre comment ça se fait que ça a
pu échapper aux autorités
il y a pas vous avez pas d'autres
explications à nous fournir que ça non
faudrait se référer aux autorités mais
les autorités c'est vous dans la mesure
où on a fait un une inspection visuelle
et on avait les doutes on a fait faire
des tests on a appelé le département de
la santé publique et on suit leur
directive nous avons aussi appelé la
santé publique dès Laurentides est-ce
que vous avez regardé le plafond des
espaces de rangement l'organisme refuse
notre demande d'entrevue à la caméra
face aux résultats de nos analyses la
santé publique nous indique avoir
demandé que la situation soit corrigée
mais maintient que le risque à la santé
est faible du fait que la zone touchée
par les moisissures et relativement
petite mais surtout puisqu'il s'agit
d'un lieu qui n'est pas occupé de façon
régulière est-ce que ça se peut que des
gens soient réellement incommodés par la
présence de ces moisissures ou sous-sol
même s'ils vivent au rez-de-chaussée et
au deuxième étage
[Musique]
qu'on voit que les moisissures
n'auraient pas les sports qui rejettent
dans l'air se mélangent à l'air ambiant
et on sait qu'une maison c'est pas
étanche
c'est à noter au dessus des tâches de
moisissures du sous-sol se trouve
l'appartement de Carol Lavoie nous lui
montrons à elle ainsi qu'à Nancy Robby
show notre rapport d'analyse c'est sorte
de moisissures contiennent des
mycotoxines substances toxiques et
représente un danger pour la santé
humaine
Julie mais je devrais poirer parce que
j'ai été victime de soi est incroyable
et je comprends mal que personne que vu
ça là c'est impossible
dans un autre HLM même souhait pour
Carole Lavoie qui ne veut plus remettre
les pieds dans son logement je veux
vivre
de façon adéquate c'est pas c'est pas
humain le vivre des choses comme ça
Claudette baron quant à elle a décidé de
plier bagage elle loue aujourd'hui un
appartement qui lui coûte 3 fois plus
cher présentement je suis en train de
faire des boîtes pour mon déménagement
c'est vraiment difficile parce que avec
le Cancer et tout et j'aurais voulu
rester ici bien sûr mais je peux pas je
dois partir je dois quitter
[Musique]
ça va mal c'est ainsi dans ce HLM de la
chute parce que après notre passage
l'Office a obtenu des fonds pour faire
des réparations mais même si Robichon et
Carole la voie tente par voie judiciaire
de les faire arrêter elles estiment que
ces travaux sont précipités et qu'ils ne
régleront pas le problème à la source de
son côté la directrice générale estime
qu'il s'agit d'un manque de
collaboration on a vu avant la pause que
le mauvais état des HLM peut nuire à la
santé de ses locataires d'où
l'importance de bien entretenir ces
immeubles mais certains disent qu'il est
plus payant politiquement de construire
du neuf que de rénover du vieux et que
le gouvernement se traîne les pieds
c'est évident que comme gestionnaire moi
je pourrais pas dire que j'ai pas vu ça
c'est ça saute aux yeux d'aucun problème
de contamination ça prend pas la tête à
peineau métro pour le voir Robert pilon
milite pour la défense des droits des
locataires de HLM depuis des années
l'exemple de la chute illustre bien le
mauvais état d'une partie importante
malheureusement du parc HLM on est dans
quel secteur monsieur pilon on ira le
quartier de la Petite Bourgogne à
Montréal une promenade dans ce quartier
de Montréal nous montre qu'il y a pire
que le HLM de la chute si on est entre
deux édifices qui se ressemblent
municipal d'habitation a eu l'argent
pour refaire la toiture atteint alors
que malheureusement dans ce cas-là
l'Office ayant pas suffisamment d'argent
la moissure c'est installée puis au fil
des années l'Office a dû relancer les
locataires à l'extérieur
au Québec ces cas extrêmes sont peu
fréquents moins de 2% des HLM public
sont barricadés restent que le tiers des
immeubles son côté D ou E c'est-à-dire
en mauvais ou très mauvais état mais
cela ne signifie pas que c'est HLM
défraîchi soit inhabitable selon le PDG
de la Société d'habitation du Québec
l'organisme responsable des HLM faut
faire attention quand on parle d'indices
quand on parle d'un e puis qu'on dit oh
c'est catastrophique vous pourriez être
eux parce que vous avez une toiture à
faire d'ici 5 ans mais c'est tout à fait
habitable puis vous êtes te fais
confortable dans votre logement moi je
regarde certains dossiers je resterai
dans ce logement là même si côté
Nancy
un tout autre avis sur son HLM où nous
avons trouvé de la moisissure un
immeuble côté e c'est est-ce que vous
êtes très anciens
elle n'est pas la seule à déplorer le
piteux état de son hlm c'est le cas de
locataire ailleurs également il faut
dire que l'âge moyen des HLM public au
Québec est d'environ 40 ans hors près de
la moitié de ces immeubles ne reçoivent
plus d'argent d'Ottawa parce que les
entendent de financement sont échus
c'est un jour important pour le Québec
pour corriger la situation à l'automne
Ottawa et Québec annonce une entente sur
le logement social le second volet
permettra d'accélérer la rénovation du
parc de logement HLM au Québec pour
préserver les unités de logement sociaux
2,2 milliards échelonnés sur 10 ans pour
la rénovation des HLM c'est historique
pour qu'il y a une entente en Québec et
Ottawa ont été fous comme des balais
jusqu'à temps qu'on réalise que l'argent
n'a pas été utilisé au profit de la
rénovation des HLM
en effet à ce jour pas un seul dollar
des 2,2 milliards n'a été dépensé pour
la rénovation des HLM toutes les sommes
pour les trois premières années ont
plutôt été consacrés à la construction
de nouveaux logements abordables une
situation qui choque le responsable du
dossier pour Québec solidaire Andreas
pour les maintien du parc actuel pour
rénover mettre à niveau les HLM en
particulier avant de m'embarquer dans la
construction de nouveaux logements
sociaux si on fait pas très beau
maintenant mais qu'on les reporte en 3
ou 4 ans quand on aura de l'argent ça va
être plus de moins sûr plus de coups les
coûts vont être exponentiels
le patron de la SHQ se défend qui ont du
temps en train de brasser une grosse
tempête dans un verre d'eau mais
qu'est-ce qui fait que vous choisissez
de dépenser cet argent-là pour la
construction plutôt que pour la
rénovation
pour être capable de sortir des sommes
le programme c'est fondamental c'est le
mécanisme pour distribuer les 2,2
milliards on l'attend toujours près de
deux ans et demi après l'annonce c'est
scandaleux parce que c'est trop long
quel que soit les raisons qu'on donne ou
qu'on invoque pour ça Xavier Leloup et
professeur alienrs spécialiste des
questions de logement
parce qu'on connaît les besoins des
logements dégradés ça des effets sociaux
des effets psychologiques et des effets
de santé physique extérieur gérant des
stats
mais quand je regarde la séquence je
trouve qu'on était assez performant on
n'avait pas de programme mais dans
certains cas on a quand même eu des
sommes qui ont été données à des offices
mais reste que la distribution de la
cagnotte de 2,2 milliards pour la
rénovation n'a toujours pas commencé moi
j'aimerais ça que la ministre à
l'expliquer aux gens qui sont dans des
tout dit dans du logement qui appartient
au gouvernement qu'à l'expliquer que on
a l'argent on voit les travaux plus tard
c'est une accepte madame la ministre
nous nous opposons au fait que l'argent
dédié à la rénovation des logements HLM
soit détournés au profit de nouvelles
initiatives
la ministre de l'habitation du Québec
France Hélène Duranceau accepte de nous
rencontrer on a de l'argent disponible
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on laisse dormir là
en attendant que tu sois prêt mais là on
a pris les sommes puis on les a alloués
ailleurs pour tout de suite faire naître
des projets qui avaient grandement
besoin de financement puis qui visait
aider des gens dans le besoin moi j'aime
mieux regarder ça comme une enveloppe
disponible de liquidité puis d'être
agile dans ma façon de gérer je pense
une bonne chose
Andres Fantasia il voit plutôt un choix
politique coupé vers
[Musique]
politiquement d'annoncer du nèfle qui
est d'annoncer la rénovation du vieux
ben écoutez je pense une critique facile
c'est que tu fasses quelque chose ou tu
fasses rien de toute façon il y aura des
critiques là la ministre se fait
rassurante il y aura bel et bien 2,2
milliards pour la
[Musique]
pour l'instant l'objectif du
gouvernement c'est de faire passer le
pourcentage d’établissements côté D et E
de 30% à 20% d'ici à 2026 ce qui veut
donc dire que des rénovations devront
commencer bientôt dans des centaines de
HLM on a hâte de voir ça